well as mentioned there was another
Republican debate last night and as you
know I generally find these debates and
all political debates to be pointless
and boring though I will admit that
during the cycle the debates have been
in spurt far more interesting than I
thought they would ever be or could be
especially without Trump and attendance
but the entertainment Factor has been
significantly enhanced by the fact that
thankfully many of the candidates in the
race seem to genuinely despise each
other and is that deep and sincere
contempt between the presidential
hopefuls that gives these otherwise
tedious spectacles a certain Spark and
uh and uh I'm grateful for that now of
course whenever the de debates devolve
into angry arguing and shouting you
always have people in the media and on
social media shaking their heads
disapprovingly and saying oh no this is
terrible there needs to be more civility
where is the
civility but the opposite is the case
there needs to be less civility it's
only when the civility Act is dropped
that we get anything that approaches a
sincere human moment from any of these
people so that's the positive takeaway
and staying on the positive note for
just a moment I will say again Ronda
sandis his best debate VC also had a
stellar night but this is the daily
cancellation where we focus on the
negative which
admittedly is what we do for every other
segment of the show too and there were
too many cancelable moments to count uh
moments that would certainly be
deserving of the daily cancellation
honors all on their own moments like
this from Nikki Haley watch we really do
need to ban Tik Tock once and for all
and let me tell you why for every 30
minutes that someone watches Tik Tok
every day they become 177% more
anti-semitic more pramas based on doing
that we now know that 50% of adults 18
to 25 think that Hamas was warranted in
what they did with Israel that's a
problem wait what slow down let's back
up here for a moment for every 30
minutes spent on on Tik Tok you become
177% more
anti-semitic that's a horrifying thought
doing the math that means that the
average gen zir is 47 billion per
anti-semitic and these are shocking
figures it reminds me of another stat
that I heard recently that said that um
30 minutes on LinkedIn will make you
177% more bigoted against Japanese
bisexuals I also heard that for every 30
minutes you spend on Pinterest you'll
become 177% more racist against disabled
Eskimos and these are all statistics and
and you know that that sound totally uh
credible and make a lot of sense if
you're high on crack or if you're a
politician just repeating talking points
that were given to you by a staffer who
is presumably high on crack whatever the
case none of it has any basis in reality
needless to say but that was somehow not
even the most embarrassing moment from
the debate last night and somehow the
most embarrassing moment didn't come
from Nikki Haley and for that we turned
to Chris Christie who is apparently
still pretending to run for president
and that led to this moment let's watch
you do not favor a ban on trans Medical
Treatments for minors saying it's a
parental rights issue the surgeries done
on minors involve cutting off body parts
at a time when these kids cannot even
legally smoke a cigarette kids who go
from puberty blockers to cross- sex
hormones are at a much greater
likelihood of winding up
sterile how is it that you think a
parent should be able to okay these
surgeries never mind the sterilization
of a child and aren't you way too out of
step on this issue to be the Republican
nominee no I'm not because because
Republicans believe in less government
not more in less involvement with
government not more in government
involvement in people's lives and you
know what
Megan I trust parents and we're out
there saying that we should Empower
parents in education we should Empower
parents to make more decisions about
where their kids go to school I agree we
should Empower parents to be teaching
the values that they believe in in their
homes without the government telling
them what those values should be and yet
we want to take other parental rights
away I'm sorry as a father of four I
believe there is no one who loves my
children more than me there's no one who
loves my children more than my wife
there's no one who cares more about
their success and health in life than we
do not some government bureaucrat not
some you look at these Jokers down in
Congress it takes them 3 weeks to pick a
speaker and up until two days ago they
couldn't promote somebody in the
military in the United States Senate who
earned their new Rank and we're going to
put my children's health and my
decisions in their hands for them to
make those decisions for Joe Biden to
make those decisions for me and for my
wife let me just say this this is not
not something I favor I think it's a
very very dangerous thing to do but
that's my opinion as a parent Megan and
I get to make the decisions about my
children not anybody else and every
parent out there who's watching tonight
you start to turn over just a little bit
of this Authority The Authority they're
going to take from you next you're not
going to like I'll stand up for parents
each and every
time now I'm going to try to be
respectful and civil in the way that I
respond to this which is why I'm not
going to say that this answer proves
that Chris Christie's waist size is
higher than his IQ um I'm not going to
say that and I didn't say it um I'm a
bigger man than that not as big as Chris
Christie but still big so I'm not going
to talk about that I'm not going to
address the elephant in the room the
point is that I'm just not going to
indulge in ad homonym attacks I'm
certainly not going to comment on
christe's weight which is totally
irrelevant I'm also not going to try to
embarrass Christie by showing you this
clip of Barbara Walters fat shaming him
right to his face
face I'm sitting opposite you but you
are a little overweight more than a
little yeah yeah
why if I could figure that out I'd fix
it do you try to diet oh Barbara I've
had I've had more diets and lost and
gained back more weight in my lifetime
than I care to count there are people
who say that you couldn't be president
because you're so heavy what do you say
to that no it's
ridiculous you're a fat ass yeah I am
why why are you a fat ass anyway I'm not
showing you that we're not going to talk
we're not going to show you that we're
not going to get into it um
but if I did go that direction I would
be wholly Justified because a man who
says the things that Christie said in
the first clip and who takes the
position that Christie just took
deserves nothing but scorn ridicule
mockery and contempt and just to be
perfectly clear morally speaking he
might as well have just endorsed a
ritualistic
cannibalism okay his position is that
barbaric and that morally
depraved and that's how we should see it
and treat it you know my wife and I have
the softest most luxurious sheets on
every bed in our home uh I don't know
how we ever got a great night's sleep
before we had our bamboo sheets from
cozy Earth these bamboo sheets are
temperature regulating which helps us
both sleep better at night if you're a
hot sleeper and your spouse is a cold
sleeper you need these sheets especially
on these cold winter nights cozy Earth
offers an array of sizes an 11 colors to
match your Unique Style and preferences
their sheets are made to withstand the
test of time my coer the sheets get
softer and softer with every wash don't
just take my word for it they have over
5,000 happy customer views on their site
what are you waiting for cozy Earth
offers a 100 night guarantee so there's
no harm in trying them out make every
night a cozy one with cozy Earth right
now you'll save 40% on your next
purchase with promo code Walsh 40 at
cozy earth.com that's promo code
walsh4 cozy earth.com are you one of the
million of American men and women
dealing with premature hair thinning and
hair loss well finally there's a real
solution that delivers on its promise
without the harsh side effects unwanted
chemicals and unpleasant smells provia
Hair Care uses safe natural ingredients
called proa to effectively Target the
three main causes of premature hair
thinning and loss provia supports
healthy scalp circulation delivers
nourishing nutrients to strengthen hair
follicles and it anchors them to your
scalp provia guarantees more hair in
your head than in the shower drain which
is what you want provia is a effective
for men and women of any age and safe on
colored treated and styled hair provia
Works guaranteed or 100% of your money
back it's that easy right now new
customers save over 50% off provia an
introductory package and receive a free
gift at
provia.com Walsh see results for
yourself right now don't wait that's
provia.com
Walsh so let's start at the beginning
Megan Kelly who who did an excellent job
moderating as I said reminds Christie
that uh gender transition procedures for
miners involved castrating sterilizing
removing body parts from children he's
asked why he doesn't support a legal ban
and he begins by responding quote
Republicans believe in less government
not
more really Chris so less government is
a universal principle that we should
apply to every
situation should we have less government
when it comes to other forms of violence
inflicted on the innocent should there
be less government involved in policing
murder or
rape would you call for a Appeal on laws
forbidding sexual assault on the basis
that Republicans want less government
not
more in fact forget about laws here in
the United States you want American
government involvement all over the
world suddenly your less government
principle disappears when it comes to
when it comes time to defend
Ukraine or some other foreign country
that's irrelevant to most
Americans our government is very
involved in sending billions of dollars
to Ukraine and yet you have no issue
with
that so so is that the principle the
American government can be involved in
protecting Ukrainian children but not
American
children is that how the formula works
in your thick
skull or is the whole less government
thing just a meaningless smoke screen
that you deploy whenever you need to
find a way to avoid engaging with an
issue that you find politically
inconvenient yes I think we've figured
it out now now the same could be said
about the rest of his answer as he
launches into a speech about the
importance of parental rights I trust
parents he
says what do you mean you trust
parents that's like saying I trust
uncles or I trust
cousins I trust step sisters it doesn't
make any sense obviously we don't have
complete blind absolute trust in any
group of people just based on their
biological relationship to other groups
of
people the trust we have in anyone is
conditional just as our rights are
conditional you can lose trust and you
can lose
rights that's what going to prison is
all about and one way to lose both of
those things as a parent is to
physically abuse your child as Ronda
Sanders pointed out at the debate making
a statement that should never have
needed to be said at a presidential
debate parents don't have the right to
abuse their
kids if you treat your kid that way you
lose trust and you lose
rights everybody understands this basic
concept and agrees with
it the only question is whether
sterilizing castrating and removing body
parts from a child counts as
abuse but that's not a question at
all in fact if that doesn't qualify as
abuse then nothing
qualifies if it's not abusive to have
your child's body mutilated then what
the hell is
abusive what fits the bill if that
doesn't there is no gray area here and
Chris Christie knows
that now Christie may not be nearly as
smart as he thinks he is but he isn't
technically brain dead he understands
basic
concepts which means he understands that
obviously it's not okay to try to
physically alter a boy's body in an
attempt to turn him into a girl or vice
versa he knows that but he pretends he
doesn't because he's a
coward he pretends to stand up to Donald
Trump you know he pretends that if he's
president one day which he never will be
he'll stand up to Putin and Iran and
China and
whoever the truth is he lacks the
fortitude to stand up to blue-haired
trans activists with they them
pronouns he he he's a he's he's given up
everything to appease those elements of
the left his Integrity his
dignity his chances of becoming
president well I guess he never had that
third thing or the first two come to
think of it but even so all in all he is
still today
canceled hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there